[Music]
well it's time to share some home-cooked
pasta with someone i don't get to see
enough these days
andy richter hey conan thanks for having
me over
i'm super excited to have you here
sitting at the same table
because today i've made one of the most
labor-intensive but rewarding pasta
dishes ever
the timpano wait is that the pasta dish
from the movie big night
that's right it's a massive pasta drum
stuffed with
genoa salami meatballs eggs and cheese
and topped with thick delicious
prego pasta sauce yes
it took me three days to make it wait
wait wait did you say
prego pasta sauce yes so this timpano
must weigh about six pounds it's such a
thick sauce let me just lift it up and
show you you're going to love
seeing no no don't bother just you know
just slide me over that jar of prego and
i'll just drink it straight from the jar
that's plenty for me
sure i mean this did take me a long time
to make no i'll be good with just the
jar of prego
oh just the prego okay
here you go pal
ah thank you okay can i get a straw dude
please
yeah i happen to have a giant straw
right here
oh man let's do this
okay andy you're sure you don't want to
try my tympanum it's right here
you can literally just lift it up oh
that is so good
i just felt a chunk of tomato tickling
my uvula conan
thank you so much hey
yeah no duh i can read the label no andy
prego is italian for
you're welcome oh okay oh my god
a squirrel is eating my gym panel
prego it means you're welcome